[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin Ihnen allen einen schönen
guten Abend den sonntagsport hat später
Christin Otto für Sie knackig gebündelt
guten Abend und das haben wir heute
außerdem Streit ums Sparpaket spdptiker
wollen E-Autos weiter fördern die FDP
lehnt das Ende des Agrardiesel
ab Krieg in Nahost das israelische
Militär entdeckt einen riesigen Tunnel
der Hamas nah der
Grenze und senkrechtschatter Pius
Paschke auch heute springt der
33-Jährige in Engelberg aufs
Podest der ampeleinigung zum Haushalt 24
folgt ziemlicher Unmut die Landwirte
beklagen das aus ihrer
spritzsubventionen und dazu gleich mehr
zuvor zu den wütenden Reaktionen wegen
des abrupten förderstopps für E-Autos
nur noch etwa 5 Stunden bis Mitternacht
werden entsprechende Anträge angenommen
nicht nur aus der SPD gibt es
Forderungen an Wirtschaftsminister
habbeck den Übergang anders zu managen
Christian
Volk in den deutschen Autohäusern sind
sie längst etabliert Elektroautos
zuletzt gab es bei deren Kauf bis zu
4500 € vom stat doch die Regierung muss
sparen streicht innerhalb weniger Tage
die Förderung
das gehe viel zu schnell warnt die SPD
Fraktion und will die Entscheidung nicht
einfach so hinnehmen wir brauchen weiter
eine Förderung denn weite Teile der
Bevölkerung können nicht einfach so in
die Elektromobilität umsteigen und
insofern wird die Debatte im Parlament
auch darüber geführt werden müssen wie
wir solche Förderung in solchen
Bereichen weiter sicherstellen aus dem
Wirtschaftsministerium heißt es aber für
eine weitere Förderung stehe nicht
ausreichend Geld zur Verfügung deshalb
werden Anträge nur noch bis Mitternacht
angenommen und nur von e-autokäufern die
bereits eine Zulassung haben das abrupte
Einstellen der Förderung halten wir für
Verbraucher für extrem misslig weil die
haben mit einer solchen hohen Förderung
von 4500 € gerechnet und ein Fahrzeug
kostet eine ganze Menge Geld und da
macht es schon eine Menge aus
ursprünglich sollte die Kaufprämie den
Absatz von E-Autos ankurbeln das Ziel 15
Millionen bis 2030 doch dafür sind die
Neuzulassungen selbst nach einem starken
Anstieg vor einigen Jahren noch immer
viel zu gering es gilt eigentlich jetzt
mehr zu fördern mehr Maßnahmen zu
ergreifen um eben diese ambitionierten
Ziele eben auch zu erreichen in
Deutschland und wir werden hier mit
einer Kaufzurückhaltung rechnen müssen
bei den privatkundinnen und Kunden
Käufer die bereits eine Zusage für ihre
Förderung haben sind nicht betroffen ihr
Geld so das Wirtschaftsministerium werde
ausgezahlt auch Landwirte sind nach der
haushaltseinigung stocksauer für morgen
rufen Sie zum Protest nach Berlin es
geht um den Wegfall von
agrardieselsubventionen und der KFZ
Steuerbefreiung die FDP hat das zwar
mitbeschlossen hält das aber laut
Fraktionschef D inzwischen nicht mehr
für zustimmungsfähig laute Kritik auch
aus der Union Bayerns Ministerpräsident
Söder legt heute im ZDF noch mal nach
Dorte Ferber adventsfrieden am
Kanzleramt so sieht es zumindest aus
aber die Situation der Ampel ist weiter
ungemütlich die Kritik an den
haushaltsbeschlüssen dauert an csuchef
Söder formuliert es in Berlin direkt so
wir sehen doch jetzt dass die Ampel
restlos überfordert ist wenn Sie jetzt
noch mal die jüngsten Sparbeschlüsse der
Ampel sehen am Ende wird alles teure
Energie wird teuer klimakelt gibt's
nicht das Ausgleich tanken wird teurer
einseitig auf dem Rücken der
Landwirtschaft wird gearbeitet und die
E-Autos wichtiger Beitrag zuur
Energiewende sollen gestoppt werden
gegen die Erhöhung des
agrardieselpreises wollen die landwerrte
morgen auch in Berlin demonstrieren die
agrardieselentscheidung soll komplett
zurückgenommen werden fordert der
bauernpräsident die Bauern machen Druck
nach wie vor steht eine Steuererhöhung
von einer Milliarde Euro für die
Landwirtschaft im Raum die FDP und ter
Lindner begehen damit Wortbruch es wäre
einseitige Belastung einer Berufsgruppe
die FDP Fraktion im Bundestag kündigt
jetzt ein Veto gegen die
agrardieselpläne an und der FDP
Finanzminister zeigt sich
offen jetzt gibt's eine Diskussion über
die Wirkungen die man sehr ernst nehmen
muss und wenn meine Fraktion und der
Landwirtschaftsminister hier Bedenken
haben und Alternativen ins Gespräch
bringen warum sollte man das nicht
prüfen es rumort weiter auch in der
Ampel der adventsfrieden ist eben nur
scheinbar
einer das ganze Interview mit CSU Chef
Söder das sehen sie gleich im Anschluss
in Berlin
direkt die lufthanser fordert laut BILD
am SONNTAG
740.000 € Schadenersatz von
klimaaktivisten der sogenannten letzten
Generation es geht um deren Störaktionen
an den Flughäfen in Hamburg Düsseldorf
und Berlin insgesamt waren über 100
Flüge und tausende Passagiere von den
Blockaden
betroffen in Serbien finden heute
vorgezogene Parlamentswahlen statt trotz
Inflation und monatelanger Proteste
gegen Präsident Alex wi gilt seine
rechtsnationale serbische
Fortschrittspartei als klarer Favorit
Umfragen sehen Sie bei rund 40% Auslöser
für die vorgezogenen Wahlen waren vor
allem Proteste nach zwei Amokläufen im
Mai seit 10 Wochen antwortet das
israelische Militär auf den mörderischen
Terror vom 7 Oktober nach Angaben der
Hamas sind bislang 19000 Opfer zu
beklagen trotz steigendem Druck und
internationalen Forderungen nach einer
Waffenruhe hält Israels Regierungschef
an seinem Kurs fest über die neuesten
Entwicklungen berichtet Susanna
Santina durch diesen Tunnel der Hamas
können auch Fahrzeuge fahren es ist der
größte den die israelische Armee je
entdeckt hat der Armeesprecher stellt
ihn vor und sagt er sei für Anschläge
auf Israel gebaut
worden der Tunnel endet 400 m vor der
israelischen Grenze die Hamas steht für
Terror wir müssen sie
besiegen immer wieder weiß die
israelische darin mit welchen Taktiken
die Terroristen arbeiten in diesen
Tunneln sollen sie sich verstecken
Schießen von unten auf
Soldaten und im nördlichen gaserstreifen
sei ein Tunnel freigelegt worden dessen
Zugang unter einem Babybett in einem
Haus versteckt war der Sieg über Hamas
habe oberste Priorität betont der
Premier der hohe militärische Druck ist
entscheidend um die Geiseln zu befreien
und um unseren Feind zu
besiegen in Gaza gehen die israelischen
Angriffe am Boden und aus der Luft
unverändert weiter die Krankenhäuser wie
hier in hananunis sind wegen der vielen
Verletzten am
Limit nirgends ist es sicher aber ich
musste das riskieren und
hierherkommen ich habe Angst auch hier
getötet zu werden wir sind überall in
Gefahr für Hilfslieferungen wurde ein
zweiter Grenzübergang nach Gaza geöffnet
doch die kommen nicht bei allen an in
Raffa kontrollieren H Leute einige
Ladungen auf andere LKWs stürzen sich
Dutzende Menschen die diese Hilfe so
dringend
[Applaus]
brauchen vier Jahre nach dem Brand von
notredredam hat die Kathedrale in Paris
wieder einen Wetterhahn der goldene Hahn
wurde per Kran an seinen Platz gebracht
im Inneren befindet sich auch eine lange
Liste mit Namen von rund 2000 Arbeitern
und Spendern die an der Sanierung der
Kirche beteiligt waren notreredam soll
in einem Jahr wieder eröffnet
werden wir sind jetzt beim Sport
Christin und Sonntag ist ja immer viel
los flott rein mit Skispringen Weltcup
in Engelberg Tag 2 und drei deutscher
unter den Top 5 der beste des Trios der
Sieger von gestern Pius paschka als
dritter vor Karl Geiger und Andreas
Wellinger Jubel bei Skispringer Pius
Paschke wieder in Engelberg auf dem
Podium die Form ist einfach sicher
gerade so gut wie noch nie und ja die
Mischung macht's dann war halt wieder
wirklich cooler Wettkampf zweiter Sprung
von der Titlis Chance bringt den
33-Jährigen auf Rang 3 nicht zu
bezwingen heute in der Schweiz aber der
führende im Gesamtweltcup Stefan Kraft
holt mit einer Weite von 142 m seinen
fünft Saisonsieg vor einem weiteren
Österreicher Jan HL in einem starken
deutschen Team wird Karl Geiger vier
Andreas Wellinger landet auf Rang
5 für eine große Überraschung sorgt sch
Langläuferin Victoria Karl im
norwegischen tronheim beim
intervallstart über 10 km Meter
klassisch verbucht sie mit ihrem ersten
weltcuperfolg den ersten deutschen
Einzelsieg außerhalb der Etappenrennen
seit fast 20
Jahren so noch dre Stunden bis zur
traditionsreichen Gala Sportlerin
Sportler und Mannschaft des Jahres in
badenbaden einiges wird neu sein auch
unser moderationsdu Lena käting und Sven
Foss worauf können wir uns freuen auf
jede Menge Christin und es sind wieder
so viele gekommen Weltmeister
Olympiasieger Europameister und viele
die sich Hoffnung darauf machen Sportler
Sportlerin oder Mannschaft des Jahres zu
werden ja und außerdem haben wir heute
jede Menge Action hier im Saal denn es
werden zwei parkcoursathleten hier sein
die über Tische Bänke Balustraden und
alles was ich ihnen in den Weg stellt
springt also es lohnt sich heute wenn
man hier ist die Weingläser ein bisschen
fester zu halten als normal machst mir
ein bisschen Angst also die Gala
Sportler des Jahres im Livestream auf
sportstudio.de ab 20 über un später dann
natürlich auch im Fernsehen klingt sehr
verlockend vielen Dank und viel Spaß
euch zwei und hier im ZDF gibt's die
Gala von 22:15 Uhr an tolle Kleider weiß
ich jetzt schon danke schön Christin wir
haben jetzt noch den Blick aufs Wetter
der geht so in der Mitte und im Süden
teils sonnig teils neblig im Norden
zeitweise Regen an den Küsten
stürmischer Südwestwind 4 bis 12° die
Temperaturen das war's von uns an diesem
Sonntag das heute journal das gibt's um
21:45 Uhr mit dunia Hayali